hello welcome to conan o'brien needs a
friend
a podcast where let's face it i'm on a
search for real friendship
i have some friends yeah some but um
shockingly few
in the entertainment industry and i
thought i should try and use this
podcast
and it's working out um very badly
i i thought you were going to say
something else no the podcast itself
does
is doing very well people really like it
uh and i
am making nice connections with people
you always wonder is this person really
going to be my friend now
i know and it's hard to tell in this
town but i'm going to give it time
okay i think some real friendships have
already started to
slowly slowly form i think so too maybe
you and barack obama have just been
regular i call
every day see that's the problem i think
i overplayed my hand with uh barack
obama which is he came
on and i think he had a really good time
and we ended up uh
him sort of more or less saying yeah
you're my i think we're going to be
friends
and then i think i was a bit uncool he
is such a cool person
yeah and i started calling immediately
you came off a little thirsty
yeah yeah yes which is a problem yeah it
would have helped if you had your chill
chums there
with you yeah no i don't think that was
the issue
i think it was yeah no he uh
the president did comment several times
on how nice it was that it was just the
two of us talking
it's weird he's a regular listener
listener to the podcast and he did
sort of go out of his way to say that it
was nice and streamlined
cinderblocks cinder blocks yes but
anyway
okay hard for a bird to fly with two
cinderblocks strapped especially when
that bird is a turkey
yep okay that one's used turkey as an
insult since a chips episode
in 1978. smokey in the bandit
who says turkey reynolds and my dad
yeah i know i can't believe you just
said you turkey
what what is this an episode of alice
you can kiss my grits
by the way we're now losing all of our
young viewers uh-huh and i say young
viewers
i know that they i still consider them
viewers i know i come from television
and some of you may think that was a
slip of the tongue
but i always think of people watching
their device
as they listen to the podcast i did it
on purpose i did it on purpose it was
not a slip up it was not me being
an out of touch boomer it was me being a
really cool guy who understands that
young people listen to podcasts
staring at the device okay yeah you
really get it
yeah yeah i do get it oh boy do i get it
yeah yeah turkey
he called me a turkey and i'm the one
that's out of touch and he just watched
smokey and the bandit yeah
sure sure i'd watch that again that's a
good that's one of the best movies ever
made
okay burt reynolds uh not long before he
passed came on the show and i went
backstage to see him and he
started giving me a back rub no no joke
that sex and it was
one of the best back rubs i ever had he
took his knuckles and he was pushing him
into my back and he went does not feel
good and i was like oh my god i'm
getting
like a massage from burt reynolds i
can't tell you how
jealous that makes me no i'm serious
that i know i'm dead serious
vintage burt reynolds is one of my
favorites yeah yeah
he was endlessly cool i bet he's done
that to a lot of ladies
no just he said just me oh you think he
you're the only person he's ever given a
massage to
he said he went out of his way to say i
know i'm i'm known as the consummate
ladies man but i haven't busted this out
ever just for you conan o'brien uh-huh
and then he said
feel free to say this after i'm gone
okay so i
yeah i remember that very well i can't
dispute it